you know I was trying to figure out
whether to do like zoinks or jinkies or
a holy something Batman or just try and
do the scooby voice but they died heck
with it Scooby Doo and Batman braving
the bold this one isn't one that I had
planned on seeing but it was one that I
actually did to be on a podcast panel
over on the fire and water podcast
network so since I saw it let's do an
animation junkie on it so this was a
little bit interesting to me I just sort
of explained where I'm coming at this
from while I do enjoy you know the
lighter animated Batman stuff I really
like Batman return of the Caped
Crusader's I like Batman versus two-face
I never really got into Batman braving
the bold eye I've only seen one episode
and I did enjoy that episode it just
didn't hook me enough for me to be like
yeah I need to set aside time to get
into this and so you know I didn't
really see it all that much I liked what
I saw and I dug the vibe of it but that
means I'm actually way more familiar
with the modern incarnations of
scooby-doo than I am with this
particular incarnation of Batman now I
don't think this is intended to be a
specific scooby-doo continuity I know
it's the voice cast from like scooby-doo
mystery Incorporated which my daughter
was into for a little while so I'm I'm
fairly familiar with you know the end
they borrowed that visual aesthetic to
so I'm fairly familiar with this voice
cast they're very good at it I mean
especially Frank Walker's friend he's
they still have the original Mike God
that man is amazing but anyway so
they've got that we've got diedrich
bader as Batman we've got all these
characters from from Brave and the bold
showing up it is much more a Batman
story with scooby-doo inserted into it
and some scooby-doo elements added in
that it is the other way around and
that's always kind of the question with
these sorts of team-up movies is whose
stories are going to feel more like
because it's really hard to just get a
50/50 balance in more often than not it
wouldn't work if you did that so it's a
question of who feels like they're the
guest in the other ones story and
ultimately this feels like a Batman
story with the scooby-doo folks guessing
but that's just in terms of the plot
structure in terms of the general
I've been the way that the characters
bounce off each other it's pretty
seamless all things to consider nobody
feels out of place and I think that's
why this specific incarnation of Batman
works really well if you're gonna do a
Scooby Doo team-up although I do believe
that there was a sort of a Batman Scooby
Doo thing before I think based on the
Adam West version I don't know I haven't
seen that I'm not gonna get too much
into spoilers on this so you don't have
to worry about that but this this was
well this was fun
this is what I would want out of
something called scooby-doo and Batman
braving the bold you know you hear that
tighter than you think
this is gonna be ridiculous and that's
ridiculous but it's fun ridiculous and
it gets the humor right and like I said
the humor of Batman braving the bullet
in the humor of scooby-doo or at least
the modern incarnations of scooby-doo
they complement each other pretty well
there are there's a couple of nitpicks
that I have while there are some nuances
to the tail end of the mystery that I
wouldn't have called like one of the
characters that ends up being involved
in it I called crazy early and like the
fact that it tastes the other character
so long to catch on to that was a little
bit boy I hope they come up with a
solution that isn't the obvious one cuz
otherwise I figured it out forever ago
and it ended up being the obvious thing
again there was a little bit more going
on with the mystery than just that I
can't really explain that without
getting into into spoilers there's also
a little bit of an added it's not quite
an action beat but it does this thing
where it's like it feels finished it
feels like it wrapped up it had a action
scene the mystery is solved we've had
our you know mask peel you know that you
have to have at the end of a scooby-doo
we've had the recap of how everything
happened and then sort of it sets off
with a new beat at the end of it not and
not like a finishing note like now they
have to deal with this and it's a little
bit odd because you're winding down at
that point
and Batman returning to Caped Crusader's
did something similar and I'm gonna
stick with my theory that I had there
and I don't know if this is true but it
feels like they wrote out the story it
came to a natural conclusion somebody
checked their watch and when
crap were eight minutes short and then
tacked on this other thing and patted
out the credit so that they could get
the hour 15 run time that is apparently
mandated for all the DC related directed
DVD movies but that's really kind of my
my only complaint and I mean you know
it's it's still on par with most
scooby-doo ich mysteries I suppose I
just I don't know I don't know if I can
safely say hey I expected them to up
their game because I'm not sure I did I
don't it just seemed like a little to of
it's like I I I should even if I figure
it out before the end I should have been
able to I should have had to have you
know put more than just two and two
together I should have had to put two
and two and two together to get six but
I only had to do like well that - that
the but I think more than anything you
know does anyone really come to come to
scooby-doo for the mysteries I'm not
sure I mean ostensibly I suppose so but
I mean it's about the vibes about the
characters is about the fun and there is
a lot of fun in it so there's some very
funny moments a lot of little one-off
jokes even from characters just briefly
appearing Harley Quinn has a line that I
absolutely loved and there and there's
some great little sort of not quite
fourth wall breaks but just like wait a
minute how does this even work moments
that there's a wonderful joke where
they're there in the mystery event and
Scooby's driving and Batman says Scooby
turn left and Scooby turns right and
Batman just goes he doesn't know
directions does he and Daphne look
something goes he's a dog duh like
nobody's pressing the fact that dogs is
driving the car but you were expecting
him to know his right from his left
what's wrong with you it was just the
delivery of that it was awesome and
there's and there's moments like that
sprinkled throughout I did laugh out
loud watching this movie which I would
say mission accomplished on that I spelt
these the only other nitpick that I'd
have at this aside from the stuff I'd
already mentioned is Scooby himself I
don't I don't remember noticing this you
know with the episodes of scooby-doo
mystery Incorporated that I saw so I
don't know if this is something that's
prevalent in more recent stuff than that
cuz even that shows like I'm five eight
years old something like that but
Scooby's voice they seem to have largely
dropped the are speech impediment where
he sticks the letter R at the front of
all his words now he like maybe will do
it and for the first word of a sentence
but then speak at the sentence normally
which was weird and threw me off and he
also doesn't do much although in
hindsight did Scooby
ever really actually do much because he
was always just kind of tied to Shaggy's
hip so the two of them were were
basically a duo he didn't really do a
heck of a lot on his own but he feels
even more incidental here than usual or
maybe I'm just noticing it more because
by removing the the weird speech
impediment you're like well that was
kind of his one thing so if you're not
doing that full-on why is he here
maybe that's a really weird thing to be
asking what is the point of scooby-doo
when I you could easily apply that to
the entirety of the scooby-doo franchise
but oh it bugged me in this one for some
reason I'm not entirely sure why but you
know what I had a lot of fun with this
it was enjoyable it was fast-paced it
was funny there's a that has ignites a
to full-on action beats and then like
like one kind of prologue one and and
the sort of actual at the end the one
that's basically in the middle the
action beat that Hackham that happens at
Arkham that's a ton of fun that's really
nice the one that happens later is fine
but like that was kind of a highlight
for me as far as the slapstick action
thing kind of went but like I said
there's good jokes besides that um I
don't want to follow this if you've got
an hour and 15 minutes and you you want
to have a couple laughs I would say it's
it's worth your time it's good for that
so those are my thoughts on scooby-doo
and Batman The Brave and the bold have
you seen it what did you think of it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to do all
that stuff you know the lights that
subscribe so I got a patreon if you feel
generous and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]